Timothy Ware Hill's winning screenplay
is Tyrone and the Looking Glass
the script Chronicles the quest of a
black boy in 1963 Alabama to find the
magical treasure he needs to defeat a
dragon intent on destroying him and his
family
Timothy would like to dedicate his
nickel win to his loving husband very
warehill
please join me in welcoming Timothy to
the stage
foreign
okay I'm I'm gonna uh be a lemming and
sit this down on the floor
okay thank you
uh
I would like to thank the academy
and all of the nickel
all the committee members thank you
thank you thank you thank you for this
wonderful evening thank you for changing
my life and our lives
um
I have to they already mentioned my
husband so I will continue with that and
thank my husband Barry warehill who is
here uh
I want to thank my other guests who are
here as well Mary gorak who's a family
friend
uh Janet Jeffries who's a dear friend
and mentor of mine
my managers from the Gotham group Matt
and Ellen Goldsmith Bane and their
assistant Daniel
um
and uh different Terry Shropshire and
Daniel Guzman thank you guys for being
here to support me
I
wrote Tyrone and the Looking Glass
because I
wanted to tell the story about
the young black heroes from the Civil
Rights Movement I grew up in Montgomery
Alabama
my parents told me stories of growing up
in the South during the Civil Rights
Movement being kids during the
Montgomery Bus Boycott and my
grandmother told me stories about being
a housekeeper
and
often the movies that portrayed that
error the Jim Crow South the Civil
Rights Movement they're rarely told from
the point of view of a child
and we often forget that
the children were the heroes in a lot of
the movements because their parents were
afraid or was too big of a risk to March
out of fear of losing their their work
and if you lose your work you lose your
home you lose your food you lose the
little security that you have
um
I love storytelling y'all
most of my career was on stage as a
performer and I find that when I write
it's often to
encourage and to find Hope through the
protagonist and their Journey
and uh I want to just read a little
something
that
I want to write to incur that I wrote
to use to encourage you all because we
are all most of us are all artists in
here but we're all humans and we're
going day to day and I think of Tyrone
and his journey as this young
protagonist fights for uh
his civil rights he's been tasked by his
father to integrate an all-white High
School
and the fear that comes along with that
but this is for all of us
you ever feel like you've been running
in place
going in circles with your tail and your
face
constantly losing ground when the road
Swept Away watching others move forward
when you're made to stay
you've got this
you ever feel like it's over before you
even begin the stench of defeat just
lingers in the wind as it pushes you
backwards to start near the end just to
run the same race all over again
you got this
you're closer than you think
the things that scare us most when faced
makes it impossible for you to break
the very thing you overcome is the thing
that makes you great your Destinies on
the other side your toes upon the brink
you God
this
though tears escape from weary eyes or
head hangs low to mask your cries you
may even start to compromise what you
believe is true
just don't forget that tears they dry
the pain you feel will pass you by and
soon enough you'll realize the power is
still in you
just like the sun that shines its Rays
regardless of clear skies or Haze or
foggy nights or cloudy days or absent
from your view
you just have to fully know
the seeds you plant the time you sow
requires rain some Growing Pains to
sturdy Roots below
and over time you will find but you have
to give it time
your Harvest will be plentiful your
world will start to grow
I'm telling you you've got this
now pick yourself up off the ground
it won't be the last time you fall down
but each time you'll learn to land a
different way
and with every bump and bruise and each
new note to fill your Blues inside their
weights a brand new tune to play
but there is no pump and Circumstance
till you get up and try again like every
great that's seen the ground before
the only way to reach New Heights the
only way that you'll take flight is when
resistance pulls you back the further
down the lack of slack than when
released you're coming back
now spread your wings and soar
you got this
these are the words that I think Tyrone
hears from his father in the scene that
these talented actors are about to read
which is when Tyrone meets Mr solid
South remember that name look him up
there's a picture
Mr solid South Mr solid South uh runs a
confectionary store a candy store and
Tyrone sees one of his treasures uh that
he has to reach and Mr solid South asks
him several questions similar to uh poll
tax that many
blacks Negroes coloreds had to answer in
order to vote back in the day so uh
thank you this is Tyrone in the Looking
Glass
[Music]